现在结婚13年，
然后全职在家有6年多，
嗯，
是想跟您请教一下关于在提升自我方面和婚姻上的问题，
我辞职在家的原因有一部分是因为工作上的事儿，
就是当时在对自己工作上的事儿心态没有摆的特别好，
然后还有我得在家里照顾孩子，
我们结婚这十多年，
我们一直都有争吵，
但是我们在没有争吵和情绪稳定的时候关系很和谐，
在今年6月份的时候，
我发现他在。
他自己所描述是精神上的处，
就是发现这件事儿，
说真的就有好几个，
他自己所说他他并不是他喜欢，
他说是在生活当中他很压抑，
我有反省过，
我自己的性格方面就是我会比较比较操心，
然后呢，
事儿事儿都想是自己能做了就让别人不要插手，
能给自己解决了就不让别人来帮忙，
就是这种心态。
但是在他看来，
似乎就是我想控制他，
或者说是不让他在家里有什么话语权，
我对这个事情一直是非常的矛盾，
就不知道该怎么去处理，
对婚姻和对他是有感情，
但是我也对现在的生活挺疲惫的，
我觉得他给我所去表达的也是这样，
所以我挺迷茫的，
我不知道是不是大家的婚姻生活都是这样，
就我已经不知道该怎么去进行接下来的生活了。
我觉得对孩子的影响也是特别不好，
其实你的这个状态啊，
在很多夫妻关系当中属于一个常态，
就是嗯，
不知道怎么能够调整一个姿势，
才能够形成一个良性的互动，
两口子才能够好好的说话，
才能够正向的去感染对方，
我记得我以前看过一个短片小说还是什么呢，
就他们两口子也是啊，
也没有什么太原则性的问题啊，
老公也没有什么恶习啊，
也没有什么在外面就找人了，
他可能有点心猿意马，
就是如果他心里面喜欢谁，
想爱护谁，
这东西他是我们任何人都控制不了的，
就是说从行为上，
她只要履行了一个丈夫的职责，
行为上她有一个父亲的担当，
有一个父亲的责任。
有的时候我跟你说，
我们作为女人，
作为妈妈，
特别愿意，
就是过度的关心，
过度的要求别人，
按照我们的想法，
比如说孩子穿一件呃裤子，
还有两件裤子，
孩子今天穿什么鞋子，
过度的去控制他们关心这个东西，
人家需要叫关心，
人家不需要就叫控制。
所以现在如果你的老公已经很明确的反馈给你了，
他觉得他挺受控制的，
那你有的时候就收着点例子啊，
说你今天想让他穿一件外套好。
他不愿意穿，
他表达了，
我就想他今天要是不穿这件外套的话，
会不会死，
他不会死吧，
那就随他吧，
对孩子也是这样，
你想让孩子穿，
嗯，
穿袜子啊，
穿厚一点，
他不愿意穿，
好，
我就想他今天不愿意穿这个靴子的话，
他会不会死，
他不会死，
好，
那就随他吧。
你突然就是当你用这个标准去衡量你和你的老公，
和你的孩子之间的关系的时候，
他们也会很轻松。
我有时候想，
原生家庭对于这个人的一个影响真的是潜移默化的呀，
就是我根本没有去关注过他们婚姻，
但是我似乎又活成了他们的样子，
又不知道怎么从这种困境里走出来。
认识就识别，
这是第一步，
就是咱俩连完麦了之候，
你今天就做一个识别，
当你想要让别人干什么事儿的时候，
你就在你的笔记本里，
心里有一个笔记本，
你画一个1，
当你想要孩子要穿什么衣服的时候，
你心里画一个1，
当你想要你老公干什么事的时候，
你在心里又画一个1。
你看你一整天下来画的这些1，
所代表那些事情，
如果他们不干，
能坏到哪里去？
如果最坏的那个结果，
你都能接受。
那他不干就不干吧，
我试试这个方法，
那我有的时候就是我经常看别人就像好像在看自己一样，
就是把别人当成自己的一个镜子一样，
大家都可以去看一下，
再见爱人啊，
但是大家看在见爱人，
请大家都抱着善意啊，
不要恶意的去批评任何人啊。
我老看到那个麦琳想要让她老公去拍照，
她老公说啊，
我现在不想拍照，
麦琳就说你现在拍呀，
老公说我现在还没有拍照的欲望，
麦琳就说你现在正好拍呀，
给我们拍呀，
其实我那个时候我就在想，
其实我们好多女人都跟麦林是一样的，
人家不想拍照的时候，
老老说，
哎，
我觉得你该拍就拍，
不拍照这事能死吗？
人家现在不想拍，
说我老公你给我拍个照，
他现在我这个觉得角度不好，
我没有拍照的欲望，
号，
这个对话就结束了，
就不会再要求他去说你现在一定要给我拍。
麦玲我也有关注过，
从他身上个别的一些点我能看到我自己打从我们结婚或者谈恋爱的时候，
他就发现我就是这样，
所以并不是说我全职之后才变成这样，
就是我也挺累的，
说心里话，
我这种状态我自己也会觉得挺拧巴的，
就不知道自己以前的状态，
他呢，
是一直知道，
他没有和我说过，
我自己不知道，
他近几年告诉我之后，
我才慢慢的去反省自己，
然后再去回想，
哦，
原来他忍了这么多年，
突然觉得就是我，
我挺内疚，
但是我又不知道该怎么去把这个事情给。
对，
反转过来你就记住一回合原则，
一回合原则就是我要求你干什么事情，
你拒绝我一次了，
我就不会有第二个回合，
你就用这个一回合原则，
你坚持在你的生活当中，
你用一个星期，
包括你对孩子，
包括你对你老公，
就是任何不涉及那个善恶，
不涉及侵害别人利益的那些事情的话，
都是一回合原则。
还有一件事情就是关于他妈妈的和我之间的事情，
我们之间表面上非常和谐，
然后孩子的爷爷奶奶对于我们的家庭和我们的孩子也非常的照顾，
这点我心里面特别感激，
但是我是最近才知道他对我的成见会非常大，
婆婆对你的成见对对对，
包括她对我的原生家庭成见也很大，
他觉得对我们的小家庭付出就很多，
然后我的家庭没有她付出的多，
她心里很不平衡，
她告诉我说，
我觉得我妈呀，
我跟谁结婚她都不喜欢，
我真的不知道为什么，
有了这句话，
你不相当于自己有了一个免死金牌吗？
反正你妈谁当儿媳妇儿她都不不一定满意，
而且我跟你说，
这样的婆婆挺多的，
好多婆婆都这样，
她儿子找谁她都不满意，
这一下不就给你松绑了吗？
如果你心里老觉得我想要成为一个我婆婆满意的儿媳妇的话，
那你心里就会很难受。
会觉得可能他对我就不满意呢，
如果你心里有一天想了，
反正谁当你儿媳妇你都不会满意的，
那我就不难受，
跟我没关系，
跟你妈妈自己有关系，
理解这个逻辑了吗？
明白还有一个问题，
他家里对他的妹妹十分宠爱，
他对他父母，
对他妹妹的这个宠爱，
我现在都十几年了，
才发现他心里对这件事情已经到达了，
我认为我看着都挺扭曲的，
他会在我们任何事情都能把他这种。
心里面这种特别不平衡啊，
甚至产生了嫉妒的这种心态，
然后能够对比到我们生活里，
我有时候也在劝他，
但是我发现没有办法去劝他，
我不知道他的这种想法会不会影响到我们之间的这种相处，
这个事情我们要回到什么啊，
个人有个人的缘法，
个人有个人的人生课题，
我们很多时候呢劝呢，
是我们出自于我们的善心，
希望他能够解开心里面那个心结，
但是他心里面如果说从小到大觉得爸爸妈妈偏心妹妹那个心结的话，
或许啊，
只有他自己人生当中遇到了什么事儿，
他自己解开才是那个缘法才到了，
就是你不必强求，
允许他心里有嫉妒，
允许他自己心里对自己的妹妹有排斥，
这是他的事儿，
这是他的人生课题，
这是他的一种情感纠结，
就如果说我们假设我们能量很强啊，
我们像大海一样包容，
我们能够帮他解开这个心结，
自然是好，
如果我们不能，
我们不要去强求，
允许他心里有心结，
他经常会在我面前抱怨或者诉苦，
所以我是劝他，
也不是不劝，
也不是对我要是只是听听，
他就不乐意，
他说你怎么不去向着我呀，
你怎么不替我说说话呀？
我要替他说话了，
他就他就觉得我说的又不够，
我要是。
站在中立的角度，
他就会告诉我说，
你看这么多年了，
也没人向着我，
然后他们都向着他，
我结婚了，
你也不向着我，
哎呀，
搞得我就特别为难，
那一瞬间你可以把他当成一个孩子，
你就顺着孩子的心意跟他聊一聊，
捋一捋，
就像一个给他捋捋毛，
那心里舒服舒服就可以了。
不一定要解决这个问题，
不一定要打开他的心结，
你就把他当成一个小孩，
捋捋他的顺毛就可以了，
就是让他在当下的那个情绪稳定就可以了。
是这个意思吗？
对，
是这个意思，
他今年6月份让我发现他在外面的这件事情，
说来真是有意思，
他在跟我道歉的时候，
总共说了连一分钟都没有，
但是他一直在跟我控诉他的原生家庭对他造成的伤害。
在我看来，
这个前后没有任何关系，
在心理学上也有这个讲究，
就是他做错事的时候吧，
他会拿一个不是理由的理由来说明他做错事这件事情的正当性，
他在心理学上其实每个人都是一个小孩儿，
你就去观察小孩的行为模式的话，
你能理解他，
就他心里知道他在外面喜欢上别人这件事情是错的，
但他要为做错事情要找一个借口和理由，
哪怕这个借口和理由在做看来是非常可笑的，
且没有关联的。
但他一。
要这么干，
就有的时候你你就转变一下思维，
就把他当成一个小孩儿，
他心里有一个小孩儿就可以了，
行，
也就是像我这样全职在家这些年，
如果现在去走向社会，
因为我有去找各种各种工作，
就是除了年龄以外，
条件都是符合的，
我现在已经不知道这条路该怎么走了，
现在实话实说啊，
大学生研究生就业都不太好找工作，
所以有的时候我们是要放下自己曾经的尊荣，
打碎自己曾经的形象，
就是说白了就脱下那个孔乙己的长袍，
如果你能接受那种真的付出劳动能挣钱的工作的话，
那可能是很好找的。
好吧，
我明白了，
谢这个故事的话，
她是很有借鉴价值的，
因为现在生活当中，
我相信我直播间有很多姐妹都处于这样一个困顿当中，
就你很想把日子过好，
很想两口子关系啊，
对吧，
有时候有笑的，
就是一个良性的循环，
但你就觉得不知道怎么就挺别扭的，
挺不顺心的，
如果你是这个状态的话，
你就试试我刚刚讲的那几个方法，
就是一回合原则，
不管是对儿子女儿，
对老公都是一回合原则，
就是我提个建议，
你要采纳你就采纳，
你不采纳的话我也不多嘴了，
这日子会轻松一点，
会慢慢慢的好过一点。
还有就是有的时候婆婆和儿媳妇的关系啊，
就刚才这个姐妹啊，
确实是这样，
很多婆婆都觉得自己的儿媳妇儿，
嗯，
她不管找谁对这个儿媳妇儿都觉得配不上自己的儿子，
这是一个婆婆的好多婆婆的共性，
是吧，
没错吧，
我从一开始我就想，
我也不想成为一个特让人特别满意，
怎么怎么样的儿媳妇儿，
我觉得那个太难了，
所以我从一开始就破罐破摔，
所一开始我就不想，
我就不想成为一个什么让谁都特别满意的儿媳妇儿，
那样自己过得可好了。